this morning top elected republicans in
arizona are going at each other over an
audit of the 2020 election now
local gop officials say the audit is a
sham
and it's time for all republicans to
stand up and to stop it
chris van cleave has been covering the
story so chris break this down for us
sure thing good morning this is turning
into a republican-on republican rumble
in arizona's biggest county the board of
supervisors lashed out in a tense
meeting yesterday
calling the exercise a grift disguised
as an audit
they say the private company hired to
lead it has no experience and quote
don't know what they're doing now
election officials
say auditors are in way over their heads
and are demanding the recount be stopped
the department of justice has warned of
possible election law violations
the board is fighting back against
allegations by the senate president
that the county is not complying with
the audit didn't properly secure ballots
and deleted data
those allegations caught the attention
of former president donald trump
who said the claims are quote
devastating in response the maricopa
county recorder a republican stephen
richard
called trump's statement quote unhinged
and is calling on other republicans to
stop
the audit here's the board of
supervisors vice chairman also a
republican
i want to be clear that i uh believe
that joe biden won the election all
right
and the reason that i feel confident in
saying that particularly in maricopa
county
is that we overturned every stone we
asked the difficult
questions all right and we certified the
election
back in november but now it's time
to say enough is enough it is time to
push back on the big lie
we must do this we must do this as a
member of the republican party
we must do this as a member of the board
of supervisors we need to do this as a
country
otherwise we are not going to be able to
move forward
and have an election in 2022 that we can
all believe the results
whatever they may be a new cbs news poll
of republicans shows
67 percent do not believe joe biden is
the legitimate winner of the 2020
election
the audit is currently on pause due to
the venue hosting high school
graduations this week
only about 25 percent of the ballots
have been reviewed so far
workers have been seen checking ballots
with uv lights looking for a watermark
rumored to be a sign of fraud
that is something out of a q anon
conspiracy theory and is not based
in fact we were there last week watching
the audit what we saw
definitely raises questions the work is
expected to resume
next week anthony grift disguised as an
audit chris van cleave thank you very
much